The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hello.
Welcome.
Today we're going to talk about
one last new topic which
has to do with search.
So as you remember, we're
working on our last topic.
The last topic was probability
and planning.
Last lecture we talked
about probability.
Mostly we focused on Bayes'
theorem, Bayes' rule.
That was a way of updating our
belief about some situation
based on new information.
And this week in Design Lab 12,
you'll get a chance to use
that in a robot application.
The idea to Design Lab 12 is
going to be that a robot is
pedaling along a corridor
with some
obstacles off to its left.
And the idea will be, you don't
know where the robot is,
but the robot will be able to
estimate where it is by the
signals that it receives from
its left-facing sonars.
So this is a very realistic
type of
state-estimation problem.
The idea is going to be that at
any given time, t, you have
access to your previous belief
at time t minus 1.
And you have access to a new
observation, which is the
sonar to your left.
And based on those two bits of
information, you will update
your belief.
Which means that when you start
out you'll have no idea
where you are, but that
situation should
improve with time.
Ok.
So that's what we're going
to do in Design Lab 12.
Today we're going to blast
ahead and think about the
other important topic,
which is search.
So we're going to think
about planning.
We're going to be
planning ahead.
We're not going to just
react to the situation
that's given to us.
We're going to try to figure out
what's the right thing to
do in the future.
And to do that, we're going to
think about all the things we
could possibly do, search
through that space, and figure
out the one that's, quote,
"best." And we'll have to
define "best" somehow.
Just to get going, I want to
show you a very simple kind of
a search problem.
This is called the
eight puzzle.
The idea is to make a plan to
go from this configuration,
which we'll call the state, to
this configuration, which
we'll call the goal state.
And on each move, you get to
move one of the tiles into the
free space.
So I could move the 8 to the
right or the 6 down.
Those are the only two things I
could do in the start state.
So I have to make up my
mind which of those I
would like to do.
And I would like to believe
that ultimately, after a
series of moves, I'm going to be
able to control this state
into that state.
And you can imagine guessing.
And we'll estimate in a moment
how big is the guess space.
I mean, if the guess space only
had like four elements in
it, guessing's a
fine strategy.
If the guess space has a lot
more elements than that,
guessing's probably
not a good idea.
So I previously ran our search
algorithms, the ones that
we'll develop during lecture,
on this problem.
And here's the solution
that our search
algorithm came up with.
It's not exactly what you might
do the first time you
touched it.
OK, I made it.
If you were counting,
I made 22 moves.
The question is, how difficult
was that problem and how good
was that solution?
Was that a good solution
or a bad solution?
Is there a better solution?
How much work did I have
to do in order to
calculate that solution?
To get a handle on that,
let's start by
asking a simple question.
How many configurations
are there?
I got there in 22.
What was the space of things
I had to look through?
How many different board
configurations exist?
So think about that
for 20 seconds.
Talk to your neighbor.
And figure out whether it
is 8-squared, 9-squared,
8-factorial, 9-factorial,
or none of those.
So how many bar configurations
do you see?
Raise your hand, show me a
number of fingers, so I can
figure out roughly how people
were-- that's excellent.
Very good participation, and
nearly 100% correct.
The answer is number (4).
You can think about this.
What if you took all the tiles
out and threw them on the
floor, and then put them
in one at a time?
Well, you would have 9
possibilities for where you
wanted to put the first one.
Then you would have 8
possibilities for where you
wanted to put the second one.
Then you'd have 7 possibilities
for where you
put the third one, et
cetera, et cetera.
Even though the space doesn't
have a number on it, it still
sort of counts.
And so you end up with
9-factorial.
And the point is, 9-factorial
is a big number.
9-factorial is 362880.
So if you thought about simply
guessing, that's probably not
going to work all that
well, right?
Even if you guessed,
you have on each--
there's a third of a million
different configurations that
you have to look at.
And that's if you didn't
lose track of things.
If you lost track of--
Oh, my.
It's coming up--
almost, anyway.
It looks like it's chopped
off at the top.
So ignore that for now.
Look over here.
So even if you didn't confuse
yourself, there's a space of a
third of a million things
to look at.
And if you confused yourself,
there's even more.
So it's not a huge problem by
computer science standards.
But it's certainly not
a trivial problem.
It's not something that you can
just guess and get right.
So what we want to do today is
figure out an algorithm for
conducting a search like that.
We'd like to figure out the
algorithm, analyze how well it
works, optimize it, and try to
find out a way to find the
best solution, where "best" for
this particular problem
would mean minimum
path length.
So figure out the best solution
by considering as few
cases as possible.
Obviously, if you enumerate
all the
cases, that should work.
The problem is, it will be
interesting to solve problems
where that enumeration
is quite large.
Even here, the enumeration
So let's think about
the algorithm.
And I'll think about the
algorithm by way of an even
simpler, more finite problem.
What if I thought about a grid
of possible locations
where I could be.
Maybe this is the intersections
of streets in Manhattan.
I want to go from point A
to point I. What's the
minimum-distance path?
I hope you probably can
all figure that out.
What I want to do is write
an algorithm that
can figure that out.
And then if we write the
algorithm well, we'll be able
to use it for the tile problem,
which is not quite so
easy to do.
The way we're going to think
about doing that is to
organize all of our possible
paths through
that maze, in a tree.
So if I started at A, I have
a decision to make.
I could either go to B or D.
Then if I went to, say, B, I
could either then go to A or C
or E. I've organized them
alphabetically for no
particularly good reason.
Just--
I needed some order.
Then if I went from A to B to A,
say, then I could either go
from A to B or D. That's
illustrated here.
So the idea then--
ah, it works.
So now it looks like they're
all three working.
So the idea is, think about
the original problem.
The original problem is
find the shortest path
through some grid.
I want to go from A to I. And
I'll think about all the
possible paths on a tree.
Then the problem is that for
the kinds of problems we're
going to look at, that tree
could be infinite in length.
Oh, that's a bummer.
That means that the strategy of
building the tree and then
searching it is probably
not a good strategy.
So what we'll do instead is,
we'll try to write the
algorithm in such a way that
we construct the tree and
search for the best solution
all in one pass.
Then hopefully, if we find a
solution in some finite number
of steps, we'll only have
built part of the tree.
But we'll have built the part
that has the answer.
The idea, then, is going to be,
think about what is the
path we want to take, by
thinking about the tree of all
possible paths.
But what we want to do is write
code that will construct
the tree on the fly, while it's
considering how good were
all the different nodes.
Ok.
So how are we going
to do that?
We'll be working in Python,
not surprisingly.
We'll represent all the
possible locations.
We'll call those states.
So the problem will have states
A, B, C, D, and we'll
just represent those
by strings.
That makes it flexible.
That makes it arbitrary.
Then we'll think about
transitions, not by
enumerating them.
Remember, we don't want to
enumerate them, because there
could be infinitely
many of them.
So how's the other way
we could do it?
Well, we'll embody that
information in a program.
We'll write a procedure called
"successor" that will, given
the current state and action,
figure out the next state.
So that's a way that we can
incrementally build the tree.
So imagine here, if I started
in A and I executed action 0
or 1, I would end up in
B or D, respectively.
So I tell you the current state
and the current action,
and the successor program
then will return
to you the new state.
That's all we need to construct
the tree on the fly.
Then, to specify the particular
problem with
interest, I have to tell
you where you start.
So I have to define
initial state.
And I have to tell
you where to end.
I could just tell you
the final state.
But in some of the problems of
the type that we will want to
do, there could be multiple
acceptable answers.
So I don't want to just give
you the final state.
I'll give you a test.
I'll give you another procedure,
called "goalTest."
And that goal test, when passed
an input which is a
state, will tell you whether or
not you reached the goal.
That way, for example, all the
even-numbered squares could
satisfy the goal, if that were
the problem of interest.
Or all the states on the right
could satisfy the goal.
It's just a little bit
more flexible.
The idea, then, is that in order
to represent that tree,
we'll do it by specifying a
procedure called successor and
specifying the start state
and the goal test.
So here's how I might set that
up for the simple Manhattan
problem that I showed--
that I started with.
So I want ultimately to have
something called successor
that eats a state
and an action.
I've built the structure of
Manhattan into a dictionary.
The dictionary lists
for every state--
A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I--
for every state, it associates
that state with a list of
possible next states.
So if I'm in A, I could next be
in B or D. I could next be
in B or D.
I've organized these arbitrarily
in alphabetical
order so I can remember
what's going on.
So the next states are all
in alphabetical order.
The number of next states
depends on the state.
I'm not going to worry
about that too much.
I'm just going to specify the
action as an integer--
0,1,2,3 --
however many I need.
So the possible actions are
taken from that list.
The possible action might be
do action 0, do action
1, do action 2.
So if I did action 2 starting
on state E, I would go to--
so action started at 0 --
so 0, 1, 2 --
I would go to state F. OK?
Is that all clear?
The initial state is A, and the
goal state is, return S
equal to I. So if S is equal
to I, it returns True.
If S is not equal to I,
it returns False.
I'm not quite done.
That's enough to completely
specify the tree, but now I
have to build the
tree in Python.
Not surprisingly, from our
object-oriented past, we will
use an object-oriented
representation for that tree.
So we'll specify every node in
the tree as an instance of the
class SearchNode.
SearchNode is trivial.
SearchNode simply knows,
what was the
action that got me here?
Who's my parent?
And what's my current state?
So when you make a new node,
you have to tell the
constructor those
three things.
What was the action
that got me here?
What's my current state?
And who is my parent?
Knowing the node, you're
supposed to know the entire
path that got you here.
So we'll also add a method
which reports the path.
So if I happen to be in node
E, my path ought to be I
started in A, I took action 0
and got to B, and then I took
action 2 and got to E.
This subroutine is
intended to do that.
If my parent is "none," which
will happen for the initial
state, simply report that the
path to me is none, A.
However, if I'm anybody other
than the initial node, if I'm
other than the initial node,
then figure out the
description of the path to my
parent, and add the action
that got me here,
and my state.
So that's what this is.
OK, so what are we doing?
We specify a problem by telling
you the successor
function, the start state,
and the goal test.
Then we provide a class by which
you can build nodes to
construct, on the fly,
the search tree.
Now we're ready to write
the algorithm.
Here's the pseudocode
for the algorithm.
What do we do?
We initialize--
so we're going to be
doing a s-- oh,
this is very confusing.
I'm trying to solve
a search problem.
To solve the search problem,
I'm going to
search through the tree.
So I'm going to think about the
state of my search through
the tree by way of something
we'll call the agenda.
Very jargon-y word.
I completely apologize for it.
I didn't invent it.
It's what everybody calls it.
Sorry.
The agenda is the set
of nodes that I'm
currently thinking about.
So I'll initialize that to
contain the starting node.
Then I'll just systematically
keep repeating the same thing
over and over again.
Take one of the nodes out of
the agenda, think about it,
replace that node
by its children.
While I'm doing that, two things
are supposed to happen.
I'm supposed to construct
the search tree.
But I'm also going to be looking
over my shoulder to
see if I just constructed a
child who is the answer.
Because if I just constructed
the answer, I'm done.
Ok.
So initialize the agenda
to contain just
the starting node.
Then repeat the following
steps.
Remove one node from
the agenda.
Add that node's children
to the agenda.
And keep going until one
of two things happens.
Either you found it--
goal test returned True--
or the agenda got empty,
in which case there
must not be a solution.
If I've removed all of my
options and still haven't
found anything, then there's
no solution.
Ok.
So what's the program
look like?
It's actually remarkably simple,
especially when you
think about just how hard
the problem is.
Imagine if you wanted to do that
tiles problem with a very
simple-minded "if this then
this, if this then this."
We're talking about a third
of a million ifs, right?
That's probably not the
right way to do it.
This program is going to end
up being about this long.
It'll fit on this page.
And it's going to be able to
handle that case, or even
harder cases.
Define the search procedure.
The search procedure is
something that's going to take
the initial state, the goal
test, the possible actions,
and the successor sub routine,
the successor procedure.
That's everything you need
to specify the problem.
And it's going to return
to me the optimal path.
First, step (1).
Initialize the agenda to
contain the start node.
I want to put the
start node in.
Well, there's a chance--
I want this procedure to
be general purpose--
there's a chance that that
start node is the answer.
So take care of that first.
If you're already there,
return the answer.
The path to the answer is me.
I'm trying to create
the agenda.
I'm trying to put the first
node into the agenda.
There's a chance that first
node is the answer.
If that first node's the answer,
return the path to me.
Which is, take no action.
You're here.
But that's not likely to be
the case for the kinds of
questions we ask, in which case
we will create a list
that contains one node, which
is the node that represents
the start node.
Then, repeat 'remove
a node' -- which
we'll call the parent--
from the agenda.
And substitute --
replace that node that we pulled
out of the agenda --
replace that with
the children.
While not empty of agenda--
empty is some kind of a
pseudo-routine that I'm going
to fill in, in a minute--
while the agenda is not empty,
get an element out of the
agenda, which we'll
call the parent.
Then I want to think about
all the children.
Well, there's a list of
possible actions.
So for a in actions, do
the following things.
Each parent can have multiple
children, one for every
possible action.
So for a in action, figure out
what would be the new state.
The new state is just the
successor of the parent state.
Remember, the parent
is a node, right?
The parent is a node.
We're constructing nodes
in the search tree.
But nodes know their state.
So figure out the new state,
which is the successor of my
parent, the guy that I pulled
out of the agenda.
Make a new node, which
corresponds to this child.
Then ask the question,
did the new state
satisfy the goal test?
If it did, the answer is the
path to the new node.
Ok.
So create a new state, which is
the successor of the parent
under the given action
A. Create a new node.
See if it's the end.
If it is, just return,
I'm done.
Return from search.
Otherwise, add it-- again, one
of these pseudo-procedures.
We'll fill that in,
in a minute--
add the new node into
the agenda.
There's several things
that could happen
when I run this loop.
If the node has no children, I
will take out the parent and
not put anything back in.
If the node has multiple
children, I could take out one
node and put in more nodes than
I took out, so the agenda
could get longer.
So the agenda could either
increase in length or decrease
in length as a result of
spinning around this loop.
Also, we could either identify
a goal or fail
to identify a goal.
So as it's increasing and
decreasing, we either will or
won't find an answer.
Ok.
Now the trick--
the only thing that makes
this complicated--
is that order matters.
So those pseudo-operations,
whatever they were--
get element and add--
exactly how I get element and
exactly how I add it to the
agenda affects the way
I conduct the search.
Let's think of something
very simple.
Let's always remove the first
node from the agenda and
replace it by its children.
So pull out the first node.
And put back into the beginning
of the agenda the
children of the first node.
How?
I would start out in step (0).
I would put the start node
into the agenda.
So now there's one element in
the agenda, the start node.
Then, on the first pass
through the loop, I
would pull out that.
That's the first node
in the agenda.
There's only one node
That is the first one.
Pull out the first one and
replace it by its children.
Its children are AB and AD.
I'm representing the nodes in
this notation by the path,
because the same state
can appear multiple
times in the tree.
Notice that I could
walk ABAB --
which would correspond to
the same state being
repeated in the tree.
So I can't, when I'm writing
it down here, represent the
node by a state.
But I can represent
a node by a path.
So on the first pass through the
loop, pull out the first
item in the agenda, which
is A, and push
back that A's children.
Well A's children
are AB and AD.
Ok.
So now on the second pass, the
rule is pull out the first guy
and replace it by
the children.
Now the first guy is AB.
So I'm here.
So pull that guy out and replace
him by his children.
His children are ABA,
ABC, and ABE.
AD is left over.
The number of elements in
the agenda got bigger.
Next step, pull out the first
item in the agenda, replace it
by its children.
The first item in the
agenda is ABA.
The children of ABA
are ABAB and ABAD.
Ok.
Notice the structure
of what's going on.
Ignore the stuff on the bottom,
and just watch the
picture on the top.
So I start by putting A in the
agenda, then its children,
then its children, then
its children.
So when I implemented
the algorithm--
take out the first and replace
it by its children--
I'm searching along
the depth first.
I'm going deeper and deeper into
the tree without fully
exploring all the horizontal
spaces.
So I'm tracing a line
down that way.
If you imagine this tree--
I've only represented the first
three layers of nodes
here-- this tree goes
on forever.
It's an infinite tree, because
you can walk around in that
Manhattan grid forever.
There's no limit to how long
you can walk around.
So although I'm only listing the
first three, the tree, in
principle, goes on forever.
And this algorithm will have
the feature that it walks
along the left edge.
We call that depth-first search
because we're exploring
depth first, as opposed
to breadth.
That results because
of our rule.
The rule was, replace the first
node by its children.
Let's think about a
different rule.
Let's replace the last
node by its children.
We start by initializing the
agenda to the node that
represents the start state.
So that's the path A.
Then pull out the
last node in the agenda--
that's A--
and replace it by
its children.
Its children are still AB and
AD, just like before.
Now the answer differs from
the previous answer.
Because when I pull out the last
node, I'm pulling out AD
now, instead.
And now I replace AD by
its children, which
are ADA, ADE, ADG.
Repeat, and what I've got is
a different, but still
depth-first search.
So I've looked at two different
orderings--
pull out the first node from the
agenda and replace it by
children, pull out
the last node and
replace it by its children.
Both of those algorithms give an
exploration of the decision
tree searching out
depth first.
So it's going to try to
exhaustively go through the
entire depth before it tries
to explore the width.
As an alternative, think
about a slightly
more complicated rule.
Remove the first element from
the agenda and add its
children to the end
of the agenda.
So initialize it with the start
state, A. Pull out the
first element from the
agenda-- that's A--
and replace it by its children,
which is AB, AD.
Now pull out the first guy--
the first guy is AB--
and put its children
at the end.
It's children are
ABA, ABC, ABE--
and they are now
put at the end.
So that on the next step, I'll
pick up AD-- the guy at the
beginning--
and put AD's children
at the end.
et cetera, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
The idea being-- and now, pay no
attention to the bottom for
a moment and just think
about the pattern that
you see at the top.
In this order, where we remove
the first node and put its
children at the end of the
agenda, has the effect of
exploring breadth first.
So we call that a
breadth-first.
so the idea is, we got this
generic set of tools that let
us construct search trees.
But the order by which we
manipulate the agenda plays a
critical role in how the
search is conducted.
And the two that epitomize the
two extreme cases are, what
would happen if I replace the
last node by its children?
Or what would happen if I remove
the first node and put
its children's at the end?
Those two structures
have names because
they happen so often.
We'll call the first
one a stack and the
second one a queue.
The stack-based is going
to give us depth first.
The queue-based is going to
give us breadth first.
So, stack.
How do you think
about a stack?
You think about a stack by
saying, OK, I've got a stack.
A stack is like a
stack of dishes.
So here's my table, and I'm
going to rack my dishes up.
I'm going to put them
on a stack.
So I make a stack.
OK, I made the stack--
push a 1, push a 9, push a 3.
Push a 1, push a 9, push a 3.
That's how I do a stack.
Then pop.
When I pop, the 3 comes out.
Then pop, then the
9 comes out.
Then push a minus 2.
Then pop.
Now the minus 2 comes out.
OK?
It's stack-based.
So the last in becomes
the first out.
That was the rule that we
wanted to have for the
depth-first search.
It's very easy to
implement this.
We can implement it as a list.
All we need to do is be careful
about how we implement
the push and pop operators.
So if we set up the push
operator to simply append to
the end, and then pop ordinarily
pops from the end,
we'll get the behavior
of a stack.
That gives me, then, the rules
that I would want to use for
those procedures, the
get element an add.
I will use these stack-based
operators.
The other alternative
is a queue.
A queue is different.
A queue is like when you're
waiting in line
at the Stop & Shop.
The queue is, I've got this
queue here and I've got the
server over here.
The first person who comes
into the queue--
so say I push one.
So now 1 goes into the queue.
Then another person walks
up while he's--
the second person lines up
behind the first person.
Then I push a 3.
But the way the queue works is
that when I pop the next
person off the queue, I take
the head of the line.
So the 1 comes out.
If I pop again, the
9 comes out.
If I then push a minus 2 and
pop, then the next person in
the queue comes out.
And it's like that.
It's queue based versus
stack based.
And the queue based is the one
that we want to do for a
breadth-first organization.
And the implementation of a
queue is very trivially
different from the
implementation for a stack.
The only difference is that I'll
manipulate the list by
popping off from the
head of the queue.
So pop takes an optional
argument, which when
0, tells you the--
the argument tells you
which element to pop.
So when you specify the zero-th
one, it takes it from
the head of the queue.
That makes it very easy now to
replace the pseudo-procedures
with real procedures.
If I wanted to implement a
depth-first search, I would
replace the "create a list that
contains the agenda" with
"create a stack that will
contain the agenda." So create
a new stack, the agenda
is a stack.
And then rather than simply
sticking the node--
the start node--
into a list, I will push
it into the stack.
So agenda is a stack.
Agenda.push, the initial node.
And then every time I want to
get a new element out, I'll
agenda.pop it.
And every time I want to put
something into it, I'll
agenda.push it.
Other than that, it looks just
the same as the pseudocode
that I showed earlier.
So there is an implementation,
then, for
a depth-first search.
If I wanted instead to do
breadth, it's trivial.
Change the word "stack" to the
word "queue." Now create an
agenda that is a queue, but
queues have the same
operations--
push and pop and empty--
that stacks have.
So nothing else in the
program changed.
All I needed to do is change
the structure of the thing
that's holding the agenda.
Everything else just follows.
Ok.
So that's everything
we need, right?
Now what I want to do is think
through examples and think
about the advantages and
disadvantages of different
kinds of searches.
And I want to go on to the
second step that I raised in
the first slide.
I want to think about, how
do I optimize the search?
As I said, even that simple
little tile problem, even the
eight puzzle--
eight sounds easy, right?
Even the eight puzzle
had a third of a
million different states.
I don't necessarily want to
look through all of them.
I want to think now about
these different search
strategies, and how optimal
are they relative to each
other, and are there ways
to improve that?
Now some of you may have noticed
that all of these
paths don't seem equally good.
So take a minute.
Think about it.
Remember the problem.
The problem was this walk around
Manhattan problem.
I wanted to go from A to I.
This was the tree of all
possible paths from A to I.
What I'd like you to do is
think about whether all of those
paths are important.
Could we get rid of
some of them?
So the question is, can I
throw away some of the
terminal nodes?
Notice that I'm using the word
"terminal" kind of funny here.
The tree keeps going.
The tree is actually
infinite in length.
So by "terminal," I just
mean this row three.
So could I throw away some of
the nodes in row three?
And in particular, how many of
them could I throw away?
0, 2, 4, 6, or 8?
or Raise your hand with
the funny coding.
And the answer is--
come on, come on.
Raise your hands, raise
your hands.
Blame it on your neighbor.
That's the whole point.
OK, it's 2/3 (5) and 1/3 (4)
How'd you get (5) and (4)?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you have that
[INAUDIBLE] nodes, you may
know that there's
[? a procedure ?]
[INAUDIBLE] before.
PROFESSOR: Good.
If you're walking around
Manhattan, and you're trying
to go from A to I, and if you
spun around in this loop and
came back to A, that would
probably be a bad path, right?
So revisiting a place you've
been before is probably a bad
idea, if what your goal was, was
to get from A to I in the
shortest possible distance.
So that's exactly right.
So I would like to identify
instances where I go back to
where I started.
So for example, that
A. That A is bad.
That means I went back
to the start place.
I'm just starting over.
So if I think about those, I
can identify by red all the
places where I'm repeating.
So ABA, don't really care
what happens after that.
ABCB, well, that's B again.
So that's just brain
dead, right?
So I can actually remove a fair
amount of the tree by
simply getting rid
of silliness.
Don't start the path over again,
where "over" means if
you come to a place you've
been before,
stop looking there.
That's not the right answer.
And so you can see there
that I actually
deleted half of the tree.
The number of nodes on the
third line was 16.
And 8 of them had the property
that they repeated.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? after D. ?]
Are you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This B and D. So
there's no reason to consider
this D, even though the
D didn't repeat.
AUDIENCE: That would
be [? AD? ?]
PROFESSOR: ABC,
AUDIENCE: [? That would be E? ?]
PROFESSOR: ABED.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I didn't, in this
path, ever hit D before.
AUDIENCE: When it did lead to
the path there, you'll get the
same one, AD [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I guess I
don't understand.
AUDIENCE: What I'm saying is
that without getting the path
AD, I still get (2)?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this D seems clearly inferior
to that D. Yes,
that's absolutely true.
So this is a very simple rule
for removing things.
You're thinking of a
more advanced rule.
So if you saw--
if there's a shorter path to a
particular place, don't look
at the longer path.
You're absolutely right.
So in fact, there might
be more severe pruning
that you could do.
There might have been
an answer that was
bigger than 8 --
right?
And so you're absolutely
right.
Ok.
Let me ignore that for the
moment and come back to it in
about four slides.
You're absolutely right.
So what we want to do now is
take that idea of throwing
away silly paths and formalize
it so that we can put it into
the algorithm.
And we'll think about that
as pruning rules.
So the first pruning rule
is the easy one.
Don't consider any path that
visits the same state twice.
That doesn't pick up your case,
but it does pick up 8
cases here.
So that's easy to implement.
All we need to do is--
down here where we're thinking
about whether this is a good
state to add or not--
we just ask, is it
in the path?
So if the state that I'm about
to put in the path is already
in the path, don't
put it there.
If you don't shove
it back into the
agenda, it'll get forgotten.
So before you shove it into the
agenda, ask yourself the
question, is it already
in the path?
And so I do that here.
Keep in mind, I popped out an
element called the parent.
I'm looking at the children.
The children's state is called
"new state." So I ask, is new
state in the parent's path?
So parent.inpath of new state.
So that means I have
to write inpath.
Inpath is easy.
It's especially easy if
we use recursion.
So inpath says, if my state is
state, then return True.
I'm in the path.
If that's not true, and I don't
have a parent, then that
means I'm the start state.
That means it wasn't
in the path.
And if neither of those
is true, ask the same
question of my parent.
So that makes it recursive.
So consider two cases
that could either
make it true or false.
It would be True if I'm
currently sitting on a node
that happens to be
the same state.
It would be False if I recursed
the whole way back to
the start state and hadn't
found it yet.
So there are two termination
states--
I landed on a state in the path
that was the same as new
state, or I ran the whole way
back to the start state and
didn't find it.
Those two terminate by
doing returns --
return True or return False.
The other option is that
I don't know the
answer, ask my parent.
So just recurse on inpath,
and ask my parent
to do the same thing.
So that's the way I
can figure out--
I can implement pruning
rule (1).
Now pruning rule (2) --
if multiple actions lead to
the same state, only think
about one of them.
That actually doesn't happen on
the Manhattan grid problem.
Because you can imagine search
cases where there are three
different things that
you could do.
In fact, you saw some of those
when you were coding
the robot last week.
There were multiple ways you
could end up at the state at
the end of the hall.
You could get there by being
there and moving left, which
you hit the wall.
Or you could get there by being
here and moving left.
Both of them left you
in the same place.
So if you're planning a search,
you don't need to
distinguish among those, because
they take the same
amount of steps.
So since they take the same
amount of steps, we don't need
to search further.
So we can collapse them.
That's called pruning
rule (2).
That's also easy to implement.
What we do is, we keep track of,
for every parent, what are
all of its children.
If the parent already has a
child at that place, throw
away the excess children.
That doesn't sound good.
So keep track of how many
child states I have.
Make a list.
And if the new state didn't
satisfy the goal, ask if it's
already in the list
of children.
If it's already there, pass.
Don't do anything.
Otherwise, do pruning
rule (1).
And then, before you push it
into the agenda, also push it
into the list of new children.
That's a way of making sure that
if there's multiple ways
to get the same state, you
only keep track of one.
So that's an additional
pruning rule.
So now let's think about how
we would implement these.
Let's think about the solution
to a problem where we want to
apply a depth-first search on
this Manhattan problem, to get
from A to I. So let's
think about--
let's go up--
so I want to think about, how do
I apply depth-first search
to that problem?
So think about the agenda.
So the agenda, I initialized
it with the node that
corresponds to the start state,
so that's A. I'm doing
depth first.
What's the rule for
depth first?
Pop the last guy, replace
it by his children.
OK, so pop the last guy.
What's the last guy?
The last guy is A. Replace
it by his children.
What's his children of A?
Well, there's two of
them, AB and AD.
Ok.
So I'm done with the loop
for the first level.
So pop the last guy,
that's AD.
Replace it by his children.
What are the children of AD?
Well, what could D do?
D could go to A or E or G.
A's brain dead, so I
don't want that one.
So I'll think about E and G.
So ADE, ADG.
By the way, stop me if
I make a mistake.
It's really embarrassing.
OK, pop the end, ADG.
Who's the possible
children of ADG?
ADG?
Well, it could go back to
D, but that's stupid.
So ADGH seems to be
the only good one.
Pop the last one, ADGH.
And who's his children, ADGH?
ADGH has children E, G, and I.
But I don't want G, because
that's brain dead.
So ADGH, E or I. And that
one won, right?
Because I got to A.
Everyone see what I did?
I tried to work out the
algorithm manually.
So the idea, then, was that--
so how much work I do?
I visited 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And then I found it.
So I did 7 visits.
And I got the right answer.
So both of those are good--
7 is a small number, and getting
the right answer.
Both of those are good things.
And in general, if you think
about the way a depth-first
search works--
here's a transcript of
what I just did.
This will be posted on
the online version.
So you can see it, even
though it's not
handed out to you now.
So you can look this
up on the web.
So in general, depth-first
search won't
work for every problem.
It happened to work
for this problem.
In fact, it happened to be very
good for this problem.
But it won't work for every
problem because
it could get stuck.
It could run forever in a
problem with infinite domain.
This problem has infinite
domain.
So if I were to choose my
start and end state
judiciously, I could get it
stuck in an infinite loop.
That's a property of
depth-first search.
Even when it finds a path, it
doesn't necessarily find the
shortest path.
Well, that's a bummer.
But it's very efficient
in its use of memory.
So it's not a completely
brain-dead search strategy,
but it's usually brain dead.
So let's think about
breadth-first search as an
alternative.
Again, all we need do is switch
the idea of thinking
about stacks versus queues.
Take off the beginning,
add to the end.
That's the way queues work.
So now let's do the same
problem with a
breadth-first search.
So I start with the agenda.
I put in A. I pop off the head
of the queue and stuff the
children at the end.
I pop off the beginning and
stuff the children AB, AD.
That looks right.
That's the end of path one.
Now I pop off the beginning
and stick in the children.
What are the children of AB?
Well, AB could go to ACE.
A is brain dead, so ABC--
ABC or ABE.
ABC or ABE, that looks right.
Now pop off this guy, AD, and
put his children at the end.
That's ADE and ADG.
I don't think I made
a mistake yet.
Pop off the first guy, ABC.
Stick in his children ABC--
ABC, it could go to B or F.
Looks like F is the only one
that makes any sense.
ABC, that looks right.
ABE, put his children ABE--
E could go to B-- that's
brain dead--
D, F, or H. D, F-- wait.
AUDIENCE: AB.
PROFESSOR: AB, thank you.
I'm supposed to be doing ABE
followed by something, ABE
followed by something.
I don't want B. D is fine,
F is fine, and H is fine.
D, F, and H. OK so far?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh no,
it's not right?
OK, what did I do wrong?
AUDIENCE: Just AB.
It's the fourth--
PROFESSOR: Oh, here.
That's up here.
Is that [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
That would be embarrassing.
OK, next pop off AD--
This is why we have
computers, right?
We don't normally
do this by hand.
OK, so ADE--
if I had ADE, I could do B--
that seems OK, D seems bad--
F, or H. So it would look like
B, F, H. OK, ADG.
A, D, G. It looks like
H is my only option.
ABCF.
A, B, C, F. Looks like I could
do E or I. Finally.
Now the only question
is whether I got the
right number of states.
Let's assume I did.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16 --
which happens to be
the right answer.
At least it happens to be the
answer I got this morning when
I was at breakfast.
So what did I just do?
I just did a breadth-first
search.
Here's a transcript.
16 matches, good.
Breadth-first search has a
different set of properties.
Notice that it took me longer.
But because it's breadth first,
and because each row
corresponds to an increasing
path length, it's always
guaranteed to give you
the shortest answer.
That's good.
So it always gives you
the shortest answer.
It requires more space.
I mean, you can see that
just on the chalkboard.
And also it still didn't take
care of your problem.
So this still seems like
there's too much work.
I looked at 16 different
places.
I did 16 visits.
There's just something
completely wrong about that,
because there's only 9 states.
How could it take more visits
than there are states?
So that just doesn't
sound right.
And it's for exactly
your point.
And so there's another idea
that we can use, which is
called "dynamic programming."
The idea in dynamic
programming, the principal is,
if you think about a path that
goes from x is z through y,
the best path from x to z
through y is the sum
of two paths--
the best path from x to y and
the best path from y to z.
If you think about that, that
has to be the case.
And if we further assume that
we're going to do breadth
first, then the first time that
we see a state is the
best way to get there.
So what we can do then, in order
to take care of your
case, is keep track of the
states we've already visited.
If we've already visited a
state, it appears earlier in
the tree, there's no point in
thinking about it further.
That's the idea of dynamic
programming.
And that's also easy
to implement.
All we need to do is keep track
of all those places
we've already visited.
So we make a dictionary called
"visited." So I initialize
before I start looking
at the children.
I initialize right after
I set up the initial
contents of the agenda.
I create this dictionary
called visited.
And every time I visit a new
state, I put that state in the
visit list.
Then before I add the child to
the agenda I ask, is the child
already in the visit list?
If the child's already there,
well forget it.
I don't need him.
Otherwise, just before you push
the new state, remember
now that that's an element
that's been visited.
So the idea, then, is that by
keeping track of who you've
already looked at, you
can avoid looking--
so if there's a depth-3 way to
get to D, and a depth-2, then
I don't need to worry about
the previous ones, because
it's already in the visit list.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do we still need
the new child states up there?
PROFESSOR: Why do we still have
the new child states?
AUDIENCE: The placement was
based [? on-- ?] the
[INAUDIBLE] state.
PROFESSOR: I think
you're right.
I should think about that.
I think you're right.
I think when I was modifying
the code for the different
places I slipped and could
have removed that line.
I think you're right.
I'll have to think about it,
but I think you're right.
So if that line magically
disappears from the online
version, he's right.
OK, so now one last problem.
I want to see if I can figure
out what would happen with
dynamic programming.
So I want to do breadth first.
And just as a warning, I'm
hypoglycemic at this point.
So there may be more
errors than usual.
So I need to keep track
of two things.
I need to keep track
of the visit list.
And I need to keep track
of the agenda.
So there's two lists I have
to keep track of.
OK.
Let's start out by saying
that the agenda
contains the start element.
That's A. That means we visited
A. It's breadth first,
so I want to take the first guy
out of the queue and add
his children to the
end of the queue.
So take the first guy
out of the queue.
Add his children.
A's children are B and D, which
means that I've now
visited B and D.
Now I want to take out the first
guy from the queue, AB,
and I want to put his children
at the end of the queue.
AB's children are A--
that's been visited, C--
not visited, and E--
not visited.
So ABCE.
But that visits C and E.
Now I want to take out AD and
put its children at the end.
AD is AEG.
A is visited, E is visited,
which leaves just G, so ADG .
And that visits G.
Then I want to take out ABC and
put in its children, A, B,
C. ABC, oh dear.
AB--
I'm looking up there.
I said I'm hypoglycemic.
ABC--
ABC -- could be B or F.
Well, B's no good.
Which leaves F, but
that visits F.
So now, ABE.
ABE, so that could be
B, D, F, H. B--
visited, D--
visited, F--
visited, H--
OK.
That visits H.
Now take out ADG.
Children of ADG--
ADG, two children, D and H. D
and H, they're both there.
That didn't work.
There are no children of ADG.
ABCF--
ABCF, three children--
C, E, I. C--
visited, E--
visited, I--
done.
Found the right answer.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 --
8 visits.
So I've got the same answer,
and it's optimal, and I did
fewer than 9 visits.
9 was the number of states.
So this algorithm will always
have those properties.
So the dynamic programming--
oh, I forgot a slide.
The dynamic programming with
breadth-first search will
always find the best.
It will never take longer than
the number of states.
So in this problem that had a
finite number of states, even
though I had an infinite
number of paths--
because you can go around
in circles--
it'll still never take more
than the number of states.
And all that it requires to
implement is to maintain two
lists instead of one.
So the point, then, is that
today we looked at a variety--
we looked at two real different
kinds of search
algorithms, depth-first search
and breadth-first search.
And we looked at a number of
different pruning rules.
Pruning rule (1) -- don't go
to some place that you've
already visited.
Pruning rule (2) -- if you have
two children that go to
the same place, only think
about one of them.
You can consider dynamic
programming to be a third
pruning rule, because that's
the effect of it.
And the final announcement,
don't forget about Wednesday.
Have a good week.